all right we are bringing back so vegas
for the month of february and this time
it's all about black history and neon
imagine this it's may 24th 1955 opening
night of the first integrated hotel and
casino in las vegas the mulan rouge
what's left of this haven are just
stories
and signs if we go back to the 50s and
we think about people like cab calloway
or even sammy davis jr or
young aretha franklin coming and
performing
these individuals were expected to do
two shows a night they were expected to
then schmooze the crowd afterwards and
walk around and and glad to hand the pet
the patrons but they weren't allowed to
eat on the strip and they weren't
allowed to stay on the strip
i guess you could call the moulin rouge
a sign of the times so the moulin rouge
sign is really critical it's really
important
because
it tells that story of integration and
segregation here in las vegas and it
lives inside the neon museum where black
history is illuminated all year round
something their executive director aaron
berger is really proud of we tell
stories throughout the year of those
members of the black community who
really
were exceptional contributors to our
development but february is a special
month where we get to really kind of
drive that message home speaking of home
there's no telling vegas history without
black history las vegas black history is
our history
so this is so vegas in so many ways
because the city would not be what it is
today without the contributions of the
black community so being able to tell
the stories is really what the museum is
all about and whether you're inside or
outside the museum
you're learning behind me is the las
vegas luminaries mural this debuted in
december of last year it is a fantastic
piece over 800 square feet
showcasing 11 undertold or
underrepresented stories here in las
vegas
we really wanted to focus on those
people that may not be necessarily a
household name
but we want you to learn a little bit
more about so let's start with this
beauty theodora boyd a pioneering black
showgirl and dancer from the moulin
rouge we actually don't know that much
about her we don't know if she's still
alive we don't know if she has family or
relatives so we have been doing call
outs in our social media that if you
know of theodora boyd if you know
anything about her you're related to her
something like that get in touch with
the museum we'd love to capture more
information next sammy davis jr he could
do it all sing dance act play
instruments do stand up and
fight for civil rights he was one of our
casino owners here in town
he fought for the equal treatment of
blacks being able to not just entertain
on the strip but also enjoy all that the
strip offers themselves as well so he
was a very vocal proponent and supported
by his good friends in the rat pack to
help bring about change
and the last of the black luminaries mr
paul revere williams a trailblazing
architect whose disadvantages growing up
led to his designs going up both of his
parents passed away before he was four
on the positive side he was put into a
foster home where his foster mother was
very very she was an educator and really
believed in education she saw
the the smarts that prw had and she
encouraged that learning ending up to be
one of the most prolific architects
in american history
designing all whole neighborhoods here
in las vegas the west side is full of
homes that he has designed and created
himself and then of course our
the visitor center the la concha now
this is more than just a mural it's a
free and futuristic history lesson we've
added a qr code to the mural so that
someone can just hover their phone over
that image and then be able to learn
about each of the people who are
featured in the in the mural and so it's
really an educational offering but it's
definitely our gift to the city that we
love besides education another gift from
the neon museum is enlightenment about
yourself and others it's a rather dull
world if we only know our own stories so
let's explore and expand and that's what
the museum is all about